so uh this is how joe rogan used to act
because joe rogan's like we're talking
about before the show but jorgen's like
a um
guy okay see joe rogan's like um
elk hunting mj pjj
enthusiast guy see so can you see joe
rogan's like um like a dude who cheats
on his wife but his openers allegedly
right yeah that's three that's it
enough
the guy who started smoking weed later
in life also short
guy yeah you've been very clear about
that joe rogan is somebody
who started smoking weed later in life
so what happens with people like that is
like the kevin smith phenomenon where
it's like
you're supposed to get your cringy weed
man stuff out of your system in your
like 20s right you would say
early 20s we learned in high school that
weed is not a personality
trait but what happens is when people
smoke start smoking it later in life
they become weed man and you're like
you're 50.
what do you stop this doing you're being
just [ __ ] sick
this isn't even like fun this is just an
identity crisis for you
and it's not [ __ ] on weed wheat is
awesome of course not
but it's the it's the it's again like
you said that's the
making it your personality that's kind
of weird to me anyway
um here's joey diaz and you're welcome
mike because
mike has the best joey diaz impression
in the business i passed out one night
really hard
water bottle all right nelson i wake up
to the door banging
and it's joe rogan pre-marijuana when he
was [ __ ] miserable
i always say he was an ape you ever see
the evolution of an eight that's when he
was an eight
yeah if you didn't know joe marijuana
wasn't
it wasn't it was like spurts there was
something missing
thank god eddie talked him into that
because you didn't know why he was
anti-drug
yeah anti-fucking drug you know if if
bert came over and the next day he
called him you know burke chrysler had
like 16 [ __ ] beers he's got a bad
problem you know and he would just say
that i remember we went to see doug
stanhope that's how it started
and he's like [ __ ] doug is funny but
somebody's got to talk to him
about his alcohol his own like joe
nobody says things like that
it's like there you are
a little bit of credit here joey's a
typical guy friend but you don't [ __ ]
bother people by the way
let him do what the [ __ ] he wants nobody
i go why would you say he goes
why would i say that he had 11 beers and
four shots of tequila on stage
yeah [ __ ] mike calls out a wednesday
what a nerd
yeah who gives a [ __ ] nerd who cares
that's how uptight joe rogan used to be
because i don't even recognize that guy
no no oh there's the water bottle
there's the water bob
dog i'm telling you he was a [ __ ]
mess this guy
i know there's a lot of stuff that joey
diaz does that's why i crunch the
[ __ ] water bottle when i do it on the
air
but there's there's some some something
i do like about joey diaz is
he doesn't give like all these a lot of
these other comics were very scared
to just kind of [ __ ] on rogan a bit and
he he's just not the first time he's
done it
yeah you know he gave me ricky cruz and
ralphie may [ __ ]
for smoking pot the comedy store one
night i remember one time his father boy
his [ __ ] he came he actually turned
it he turns to [ __ ]
ralphie may [ __ ] says this [ __ ]
you're going to be dead someday
what a [ __ ] reason what a dumb [ __ ]
wait what
what happened to ralphie we're having a
raffle
ralphie may was michael rappaport if you
let himself go a lot
yeah he gave me also if you
a michael rappaport you'd actually go
hang out with that's probably
not have a cringe time who's in ralphie
may [ __ ]
for smoking pot the comedy store one
night
really that's that's how twisted he was
then anti
he was very by the book you know what's
his name had just died from drugs
who uh the guy on saturday night's live
his buddy on
news that was phil hartman and his wife
killed him
coke though but i know but his wife
killed him that was drugs were a part of
the involvement
yeah you you a guy like that would blame
drugs
gotcha and be like oh i was cause of the
drugs when meanwhile you're like
i don't know man i've had some pretty
wild relationships with girls who have
been out of shape on drugs none of them
ever came home and shrank me in the
[ __ ]
face yet
[Laughter]
yes please just do it at this point just
just [ __ ] look you just do it
just do it but still go ahead like
like walter white did with jesse yeah
the marcus
just do it it was radio and all that
awful heartbreak so he was very he got
shot though right something fun
[ __ ] was on the simpsons
i don't [ __ ] know i'm a king of the
hill man
[ __ ] don't call for [ __ ] handy dick
or some [ __ ] i don't know
joe that he was very and he he would not
discuss cocaine with me at that time
like
he wouldn't like i wouldn't ever [ __ ]
he sounds like because you know
everybody at that time was probably
backstage like am i um
all right do i look good all right i'll
go out there
the fact that joe rogan how do you go
into the comedy business
and not expect everybody around you to
be doing drugs is insane to me yeah
donald rawlings was
i think the biggest mess i've ever seen
as far as just backstage just lighting
cigarette you know that smoke back there
he'd be smoking cigarettes doing coke
[ __ ] just i mean always look like he
had like five places to be at once like
that guy
i've heard stories about greg geraldo
was kind of like that too though
oh yeah no i would probably imagine i
just never got to oh oh okay
you personally personally i've seen
people donald rawlings have very much
had that energy of i've got five other
places to be
right now and i need i need to light two
cigarettes at once and do a lot of drugs
just like just that kind of ah just
thinking back that gives me anxiety
ever be high in front of them and one
night we all said good night and i went
back to my room and i started watching
tv
and i just passed out guys and i heard
boom boom boom boom and it's joe rogan
with the security
joey open up the door you all right what
the [ __ ] we were supposed to be
downstairs at 8 30. now we missed our
[ __ ] flight and all this [ __ ]
i'm like hold on and he's looking around
my room and i'm like no
dog i went to bed last night and the
whole way there him and chris mcguire
are yacking like i know he was with
danny murray chris mcguire
so here's what happened [ __ ] joey
party too much that night
that's what happened for sure and
somebody calling him fed rogan and [ __ ]
it snitch joe rogan
is banging on the first off he doesn't
get up you know what i would do
i would just go get on my flight and let
joey diaz figure it out
right now i can picture you totally
leaving me somewhere because i'm gonna
go
look all right i got up and i got on my
[ __ ] flight now you
you have uber you have uber you'll
figure your [ __ ] out i gotta go
i mean and the other thing is i know
mike i know he's not dead i
just probably passed out so i'd be like
look whatever man i want to go
but like rogan's calling the security to
bang on the door
jesus christ you're a snitch joe that's
pretty crap
especially if it's a situation where
you've never had an issue like
i i could understand if joey diaz had
already od'd twice
right like if you were dealing with an
artie lang type i could see you may be
going and getting the hotel security but
i mean relax
somebody went out you know somebody
smoked a little too much weed and got a
little too drunk last night
let him [ __ ] sleep it off it happens
he's like he's a girl
like he said he's a big boy he could
figure out another flight adult
just let him figure you're not his mom
you don't have to fly with him
did that's when when we used chris
mcguire and we used to open for joe i
remember christmas
all those roasts then we get to the
[ __ ] airport and the flight's delayed
four hours
so all that yelling and screaming
i've been the guy that's just so [ __ ]
up that i'm the late one and i show up
and they're still there and i'm like hey
what's up what's up yeah i got that
extra hour and a half
it was great
[Laughter]
no [ __ ] reason i even told him i go
see the flight's [ __ ] delayed who
gives him
so used to i don't know man it makes
sense he just
seem like like like just
a narky kind of guy yeah yeah i would
agree with that i i really do i really
do think that he
he has that it maybe he had it or maybe
he's not like that anymore
but it's it's funny seeing well she
doesn't go live anymore because he got
caught trying to help twitter
help get tim pull to be a narc you're
right look i hate tim pool and i make
fun of him all the time but
you know there's a tape of tim poole not
knocking he did it narc that's you got
to give him the credit there yeah you're
right oh and joe
has not gone live ever since and he
probably still resents and hates jamie
to this day
because that got out over the air and he
[ __ ] he was pissed
how long before he red bands jamie
i'm surprised he didn't do it after that
i'm honestly surprised he didn't do it
after that that was a big [ __ ] up
do you think that was a big [ __ ] up well
i mean i
kind of feel bad for him for jamie
because you and i have both had
you know i'm sure he doesn't use obs but
a lot of the he probably uses wirecast
or tricaster which i've used before too
i didn't pay for it it's like three
thousand dollars but i did plan
this is before the days of obs and
sometimes when you do hit stop
streaming it glitches and it just
doesn't stop yeah you know i mean it's
happened to me before
uh there's there's ways around that
though you know yeah
i mean like me personally when i go off
even when i just do
it by myself everything's muted
everything gets potted down
muted there's three layers of mutes
because you never know and then i also
switched the scene back to not being on
camera
right just in case i mean yeah again it
happens with obs sometimes where you
exit out and keep streaming for a little
bit right right
what it what is going on so yeah you got
to be i don't know man i'm not
i'm i am shocked he didn't get fired but
i know he got a big talking to
and i can tell you this if it ever
happens again he's fired